pd minute es ist sauer
description daran ihr fragt euch
wahrscheinlich was ist das hier
wir fragen sicher dass ich meine
skulptur von kriterium kann man noch was
drauf steht ist mein bruder max hat mich
in hamburg hier besucht weil max nicht
tun
jack russel geiler scheiß was machen wir
jetzt gleich einkaufen
auf jeden fall steht heute extrem viel
an in meinem leben nämlich dass man kann
ich mir gekauft hatte bei den
kommentaren
das war ja sagen
die aber auf jeden fall heute einiges zu
tun denn wir müssen hier vorbereiten
dafür müssen den supermarkt fahren wir
müssen in das ist sie thoma demo tanja
tomate sie motto maße honig tomate die
dort am 12
trixi tomate und clemens praxis ja bei
mir in hamburg bei max hat nichts zu tun
wir können hatte ich noch ein bisschen
tee trinken das spiel schnell für damen
das ist auf jeden fall eigentlich meine
aufnahme ist immer aber irgendwie auch
ein gästezimmer
das ist rang bett da drauf machen wir
das licht an falls euch übrigens fragt
warum jetzt plötzlich so extrem kranke
qualität in seinen videos hat sony
assoziierte man daran wie die neue sony
a7 s3 gegeben und so krank wie genau
trifft schwanz wie meine zukunft wird
max unterschrieben
ich habe sogar echt ein paar freunde
keine unterschrift formiert was machen
also wir machen so einen coolen tag
schaut mal leute jetzt aufgeklärt aber
wenn du einmal platsch platsch ist oben
rang durch die helfen branche t wir
fahren jetzt als erstes in dem
supermarkt nicht jetzt brauchen wir
denken wow marketing aufzügen dann
saturn weg verkaufen
nicht vergessen
scheiße
[Musik]
der markt
da steht ein nein von korn genommen ja
nein nein kronskamp 25 hamburg
alles zu seiner zeit gehabt sondern neue
sd karte geholt ist direkt im schlitz
gelandet somit hat sie nur 60 euro
gekostet
natürlich luca warum sind wir hier beim
baumarkt weil wir eine strafe wegen
mussten
das machen wir jetzt
auf dem wege geht man hier nichts an
einkaufen und auf einmal sein
fußballstadion
[Musik]
was im supermarkt super supermarkt
die mischungen sind wieder zu hause
angekommen darauf erstmal am ende am d
[Musik]
ich habe gesagt da unten jetzt selber
machen drei wochen später
wie lange hat es gedauert sagt den
leuten wie lange es gedauert hat
über sind jetzt hier so metallspäne ich
glaube das ist sehr gesund durch
eingeben muss gab ich halt deine fresse
das ist sein das sagt dass es gelogen
ist halt dein maul und man weiß was von
der halte
[Musik]
ich hab die monitor übrigens
mittlerweile aufgebaut und sieht richtig
wild aus man erkennt kein unterschied
[Musik]
die anderen ja also ich glaube ich an
kommentiert kohle